before I let you go I do have to ask you
based on all the news that is happening
with the NFL and with the new policy
that has been put into place for the
national anthem how that has sitting how
has that been sitting in your locker
room over the last twenty fourteen you
know for us it's nothing really changes
because last year we had guys on our
team who had an issue with the way
things were going in society and I think
as a locker room we support each and
every one of our teammates and what they
may be going through off the field but
we felt like as a team that was best to
do one thing and you know for us it was
standing United linking arms with every
player every coach our front office our
owners we were standing because of the
respect that we have for the flag and
what the national anthem means yet we
were still supporting each and every one
of our teammates and what they may be
going through
well art Rooney of the Steelers was
asked yesterday coming out of the
meeting and this is still a policy that
that that has some potentially devilish
details for the lack of better phrase to
be figured out details to be figured out
that linking arms might be construed as
disrespectful to the anthem and the flag
so is that something that the Vikings
are still planning on doing he's linking
or I think it was necessarily something
that you know obviously we planned on it
for a few weeks it wasn't something that
we continued to do each and every week
but you know like I said I think it's
something that will handle internally as
a team but the main kind of point there
is that you know no matter what we're
going we're gonna do it as a team and as
an organization that's just the kind of
way things are run around here alright
and in that regard just last one for you
on this there have been reports that
some players are outraged at this at
this new policy and that are thinking of
demonstrating in some form of
demonstration just because of the policy
is that a conversation happening in your
locker room best you can tell no it has
like I said the the anthem issue really
hasn't been much of a discussion here
since we since it was brought up last
year during the time when it was kind of
most prevalent and like I said we
decided that no matter what we're gonna
do over and do it as team and then
really it's kind of gone by the wayside
for us the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience